>>Trevor Johns: Hello everyone.
My name is Trevor Johns and this is Android
Developer Office Hours for the week of August
1st, 2012.
This week's topic is smoothing out performance
in Android UIs with our special guest Romain
Guy.
Also with us today is Alex Lucas and Roman
Norik via video from New York.
So, for those of you joining us for the first
time we hold this channel every Wednesday
at 2pm Pacific and our goal is to answer your
questions about Android app development.
If you're watching live, feel free to hop
onto our Google Plus hangout where you can
ask us questions either via video or if you
don't have a webcam, audio and text questions
are perfectly acceptable, too.
We also have a moderator page that we use
to vote on questions beforehand.
So we're gonna go ahead and start by reading
off the top of that list and as we go along
live, you guys are certainly welcome to vote
on the question you think we should answer
next.
So, let's go ahead and get started.
First question from the moderator queue, this
is from Drew H. in Wheaton, Illinois and he
asks, "Our app is having issues with Hebrew
text and vowel points rendering to the left
of the center rather than directly below.
Is this a bug with Skia?
And is there something we can do in our app
to fix this?"
>>Romain Guy: So, I have an answer for that.
It is kind of a bug in Skia
[Techno music playing]
>>Romain Guy: kind of a bug in the open [indistinct]
pipeline and kind of a bug in the framework.
The issue that's interesting to you is that
we don't really support, as of Jellybean,
vertical positioning of glyphs are with the
complex, uh, complex character sets.
This is something we've been working on and
have already fixed this issue internally so
a future version of Android will have a much
better spot for that and should actually work
in the next release of Android.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, excellent.
Thank you.
Let's go ahead and move onto the next question.
So this one comes from Achile from Ashburn,
Virginia and he asks, "Why are objects in
auto in boxing not recommended?"
That's two questions, not the same.
Why are objects not recommended and why is
auto in boxing not recommended?
I'm not sure that's entirely accurate so,
Alex, I know we were talking about it before.
>>Alex Lucas: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: Do you wanna give a little
bit more feedback for or a bit more of an
answer on this?
>>Alex Lucas: Sure.
Okay, so, uh, to address them both individually,
why objects are not recommended, it's not
so much that we're saying don't use objects
it's the Java program.
It's an object-oriented program.
>>Trevor Johns: The Android framework itself
is full of lots of objects.
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Objects are not, in themselves,
the bad thing.
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
What we're really going for is don't use object
gratuitously where you can, where you could
do just as well with a primitive type.
For instance, you can pretty easily replace
enums with simple integers.
That's just a static constant integer.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
So for those of you that don't know, if you
do use an enum in object, or in Java, that
does get translated into a full fledged Java
object which is a lot of overhead for, if
all you want is something you can [inaudible].
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
And then if you have a large collection of
objects that have, that each have an enum
property attached to them or something that
is another large collection of objects.
If using enums instead of just normal integers.
So we're really just saying don't use them,
don't use them gratuitously or excessively.
For auto boxing, it's more or less the same
thing because if you have a large collection
here iterating over and auto boxing is going
to create integer objects like, [indistinct]
so, where just a normal integer would work
fine you're gonna be creating objects on the
fly in the loop and it's gonna be pretty wasteful
and slow things down a little bit and use
up way more memory than necessary.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
So, one, one or two auto boxings here and
there are probably fine.
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: But you probably don't wanna
do it inside the loop.
Every time that loop goes through iteration,
you have another object to create.
Oh yeah.
>>Romain Guy: The one thing to remember is
that you should only avoid using objects and
auto boxing in [indistinct].
So, in [indistinct], draw, measure or if you
have your own custom algorithms to move, you
know, fast.
But in listener, when you click on the button,
it's okay to create an object cause that's
not gonna happen very often.
So it's up to you that you would understand
your application and you know, like, what
pieces of code aren't called very often and
this is where you have to be careful.
And, also, we offer you many APIs to avoid
creating objects or to help you to reuse objects.
So, for instance, if we are talking about
auto boxing, they often come from using integers
inside of hash mat when instead you can use
the sparser way, classes we have that lets
you avoid the auto boxing and give you the
same features and benefits of the hash mat.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright.
So, I think that's pretty well covered, so,
let's go ahead and move onto the next question.
This one's coming from Martin S. in the Northwest
UK.
He asks, "What are the best tools for tracing
performance issues?
I have a slight pause when starting activity
and I can't seem to track down the issue."
Um, Romain, you wanna?
>>Romain Guy: Yeah.
So we have two tools that, well, three tools
you can use in SDK that you can use to track
performance issues.
The first one is called Trace View.
Trace View lets you profile the direct code
inside your application and you can see how
much time you spend in every method in your
application.
You can also use Systrace, this was introduced
in Jellybean.
The best I can recommend if you want to know
more about Systrace you should look at the
Google IO video that we posted a couple weeks
ago where we presented the tool a little bit.
And you can also use the DDNS application
tracker if the performance issue comes from
the garbage collector then DDNS will help
you figure out where you're creating objects
and why and then you can fix that.
In your particular case because it happens
when you start the activity, there are two
things you can do, you can either go into
developer settings and set your application
as the debuggable application and then there's
a checkbox you can turn on that tells the
system to wait for the debugger before detaching.
So you can basically let your application
wait until you're ready to start debugging
and as soon as you're ready to start debugging
you can start tracing so you can capture the
startup of your application.
You can also use Trace View from code in Android.OS.debug.
We have two methods, start method tracing
and stop method tracing.
So you can program it to capture a trace that
then you can open in Trace View.
So if you just start from a shell, Trace View
and then pass it to the trace file, you can
open it and this is a really good way to capture
only a very specific spot of a life cycle
of your application and this is actually something
we do a lot internally, we use these methods
to capture the start up of our apps and see
where we're spending time.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, thank you.
So, um, unless you have anything else to add
on that, Alex, I think we can go onto the
next question then.
So, this question is from Feetie and I believe
this was actually just voted up.
So, "What parts of an application does the
Jellybean application encryption protect?
The developer change log mentions application
assets and this is a bit unclear.
Is it possible to disable this encryption
for an application?"
So, I don't think we actually have any experts
on the encryption process here, so I'm not
sure we can go into detail as to what's protected
precisely.
If somebody does know, feel free to jump in,
But, I mean, the overall goal is to make it
so that once an APK has been sent to a device,
it's not possible for you to go and casually
copy that off a device.
The idea being if you get an APK from Android,
excuse me, for Google Play, you know, we don't
want you to go and copy that, um, onto some
site where it doesn't belong.
So, exactly what is encrypted is less important
than the fact that the APK can't be removed
from the device if you're getting it through
Google Play.
Now, I'm actually not sure, but Reto, you
might know this one, do we usually, we use
encryption even for free apps, correct?
>>Reto Meier: Yes, I think that's right.
>>Trevor Johns: Yea, that's what I thought.
So, for anything you're getting through Google
Play, um, it is going to be encrypted.
That said, if you really do wanna go and distribute
your app, um, in a way that is unencrypted,
you're always welcome to use the application
developer to go ahead and publish the APK
to a website.
APKs that are produced through the Android
developer tools are not encrypted.
The encryption is a side effect of loading
them on through an application store such
as Google Play.
So, users will still be able to side load
your application if you choose to publish
it and then encryption isn't an issue.
Alright, um, so I think that covers that one
so let's move on to the next question.
So, my tablet was locked right there,
[Laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: So this one's coming from
Michael, "What's the best way to [indistinct]
large images?
I received an 800 by 600 jpeg with 8-15 frames
per second.
Currently I create a bit map with bit map
factory in draw and the [indistinct] method
with canvas dot draw dot bit map.
I added [indistinct] and panning but it doesn't
feel smooth.
Is there a better way to go about doing this?
>>Romain Guy: Um, so, there's no simple answer
to this question and as often as [indistinct]
the real answer is it depends.
So, the question is a little too vague to
give you a real answer.
So, for instance, are you applying color filters
to the bit map?
Are you using alpha?
Are you scaling the bit map?
Are you decoding the bit map in the Android
method?
In which case, that would be a big no, no.
On what kind of device are you running?
Are you using acceleration?
So without having the answers to those questions,
I can't actually help you.
The best I can tell you is to use Trace View
[indistinct] use Trace View to see where you're
spending your time cause maybe you're not
spending your time in draw bit map, maybe
it's somewhere else.
And, yeah, without knowing more about the
app it's really difficult.
But you should be able to draw such a, such
a bit map, like this is not a big bit map
and, actually, the size of the bit map doesn't
matter as long as you're not scaling down
to a very tiny size.
So, there must be something else going on
in your application.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so our next question
comes from a mysteriously named person named
X
>>Alex Lucas: Actually.
>>Male #1: Actually, is that a live question
from the hangout and we'll put them on air?
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, excellent.
Yes, let's go ahead and we'll get to X's question
in just a moment.
So, uh, hey Roman.
>>Roman Norik: Yeah, so my question on, of
course I'm trying to stay up to date on the
APK and SDK tools when the new versions come
out.
For example, I saw there was a 20.0.1 release
and it's not listed in the news, the tools,
the developer site.
What's the best way to keep up to date with
what has been released?
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, so as far as the major
releases, we definitely announce those both
on the Android developer's site, developer.android.com
as well as the Android developer blog.
Now, it's always possibly that you can overlook,
say, a minor release.
For example, 20.1 or 20.1.1, so, you know,
depending on the extent of the release.
And we usually don't announce those because
there's really nothing, really note worthy
about them.
It's probably some minor bug that was found
that, for whatever reason, is considered important
enough to merit a fix.
>>Roman Norik: Okay.
>>Trevor Johns: So usually the best way is
to just periodically run the SDK manager and
then it'll flag those updates automatically.
But, of course, besides the stuff that's released
as part of Android open source and from Google,
there's a lot of other companies that can
release add ons as well.
There's someone there from Intel, from Samsung,
from HTC, so there's a lot of sources to keep
track of.
Definitely you wanna keep track of the stuff
from Android but.
>>Roman Norik: I was going SDK manager but
it wasn't showing up on there and I finally
turned it off, I like closed it out and rebooted,
turned back on and I found it and I've since
then disabled caching, see if that's gonna
do anything.
Not cache what's out there.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, but is there a refresh
option in the file menu?
>>Roman Norik: Yeah, there is.
>>Trevor Johns: It's possible that, yeah,
there was just some cache data locally that
was causing a problem.
It will eventually pick up those changes,
though, so.
>>Roman Norik: Okay.
>>Trevor Johns: If you just launch it periodically
that's probably the best way to watch out
for those releases from smaller releases,
both from Google and everyone else.
>>Romain Guy: Do we announce the new releases
on the Twitter account and the Google Plus
accounts that we have for Android developers?
>>Trevor Johns: Uh, not usually.
So, unless we noticed a really big bug then
we might mention something.
But if it's just a routine, just a routine
patch to, you know, to one of the existing
major releases, we don't advertise it.
>>Roman Norik: So the previews for 20 were
coming out, yeah, the preview for one, two
and three and that was nice and then 20.0.1
I was like, okay you changed the [indistinct]
file.
[Laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, that said, you know,
I definitely hear what you're saying there
that maybe we should advertise these a bit
more.
So I'll pass that along to the rest of the
team
>>Roman Norik: Okay.
>>Trevor Johns: maybe we could just, you know,
post something to Google Plus, probably doesn't
warrant a full blog post if it's just one
change but Google Plus is probably a pretty
good medium for that.
So I'll, actually Reto's right here, he manages
our Google Plus account so he probably, you
know, consider the feature request filed.
[Laughter]
>>Romain Guy: Thanks a lot, Reto.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so, let's go ahead
and now go onto X's question.
>>Alex Lucas: Actually before you start I
should point out that Michael, whose question
Romain sort of answered generally, if he's
listening to the hangout or if he's on, Michael,
feel free to just pop in the hangout and gives
us more specific information and we might
be able to give you a more specific answer.
>>Trevor Johns: Yes and that applies to everyone
here, um, if we're answering your question
we'd certainly love to see you online and,
again, even if your question is on the moderator
queue, you're still welcome to hop on and
ask us a question live.
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so, next question
here.
This one is targeted directly to Romain, so
X asks, "With ACS, Diane mentioned you did
some selective enabling and disabling of hardware
acceleration for the Nexus S. How, if at all,
did the butter optimization story change with
Nexus S?
Are there any additional performance tips
for lowering devices on running Android 4.1
or above?"
>>Romain Guy: So, Project Butter and Jelly
Bean didn't change much for Nexus S. The main
reason why we disabled the hardware acceleration
in some, not even some apps, it was parts
of the system.
For instance, I believe that it was disabled
in the status bar and the keyboard, we did
that mostly to save ram.
The Nexus S doesn't have that much ram compared
to other devices and on that particular device,
every time we bring up the driver in an app;
it takes about 6 to 8 megs of ram.
So, when you multiply that by the number of
processes we have it starts getting very costly.
We did a lot of, you know, changes in the
system where we tried to be very aggressive
about releasing the memory, make sure the
memory is used by the GPU but, you know, in
places like the keyboard where we don't need
to redraw at 60 FPS, we just redraw when you
type a key.
It wasn't worth it to enable hardware acceleration.
And, actually, I think the keyboard might
be using software on Nexus 7 or the next Nexus.
So, yeah, that's pretty much all there, all
there is to it.
So, preferences for lowering devices, I would
say, like, watch memory usage.
Usually the power of those devices scales
down with the size of the screen, so you don't
have to worry too much about graphics performance
cause your [indistinct].
So, it's really about how much memory you're
using.
And, again, without, I can't really answer
that question without more specific details.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so and, again, if
you are watching live, feel free to watch
on and give us some more details.
So, moving on, next questions from [indistinct]
in Palo Alto.
And, the question is, "What is the best way
to have low latency touch in games using GL
surface field?
Should I register choreographer.postframecallback
and then consume all motion events I've received
in the activity thread at that point?"
I'm guessing this is gonna be another question
for Romain.
>>Romain Guy: Yes, so that's actually where
you should probably do it.
It's actually the UI itself works.
So we synchronize the drawing this sync and
at the beginning of the frame we consume,
we process all the events that we actually
did since the last time we drew.
So this is very similar with what we do in
the UI.
What might happen, though, in your particular
case is you might get one frame, one extra
frame of latency because you will have to
request for render on the GL surfaces thread
and if you want that render to be synchronized
with this sync, you have to postpone it to
the next frame.
And this is one of the reasons why, for instance,
we haven't tried to do multiple, to move the
rendering off to a separate thread in the
UI docs because we can add an extra frame
of latency.
So, you can give it a try, see if it helps
and if it's not disabled then let us know.
We can try to think of other ways of doing
it and you can add an APS in the user forum
so you guys can do that kind of things.
And if it's not possible at all then, by all
means, do that and that's what choreographer
is for.
Trevor Johns: Okay, excellent
>>Male #1: Hey, Trevor, I've got a question
from the hangout
>>Trevor Johns: Sure.
>>Male #1: from someone who left but I'm gonna
ask it for you guys anyways.
>>Trevor Johns: Sure, go ahead.
>>Male #1: the question is, "I've seen some
apps use a sideways action bar, is this recommended?
It feels like it may offer some extra or better
functionality."
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, so, a sideway s action
bar, I'd imagine, is literally an action bar
that's oriented vertically along the sides
of the screen.
>>Romain Guy: I think it's what we [indistinct]
>>Trevor Johns: Right, that's what I was thinking
as well, too.
So I think the answer there is that it's not
a recommended pattern at this time.
We do go in and periodically revise our UI
guidelines so at some point in the future
we may or may not decide that that's a good
idea.
But, right now, the official recommendation
for action bars is either one action bar at
the top or the split action bar where you
have an action bar on the top and the bottom.
So then, of course, you can do things like
throw tabs and everything else in there too.
This is very similar to a question we've got
in past weeks; too, about some apps like Google
Play I believe does this, YouTube does this,
Google Plus, where when you tap the up button
it'll cause an additional fragment to slide
out from the side of the screen with navigation
links.
And our answer there was the same, we're evaluating
it.
If you are ambitious and wanna go and try
new UI paradigms, it's always something you
can consider placing in your app but right
now it's not an official recommendation and
you're actually gonna have to add quite a
bit of code to make that work, too, because
there's no libraries to go and render that
for you.
>>Alex Lucas: So, not discouraged but not
recommended.
>>Trevor Johns: Right and with our UI things,
our things involving UI, our guidelines are
just that.
They're intended to help guide you towards
what the correct solution is and by no means
there are hard rules.
In the end it really is, the question really
is what makes your application provide the
best user experience which is something you
have to look at the big picture.
Does it blend in with the system?
Does it make sense?
Is it intuitive?
Does it look nice?
All of these things are things that you need
to consider as a UI designer, so.
Actually, we have Roman on the other end.
Roman, do you wanna go and provide any more
feedback about this?
>>Roman Norik: First, can you guys hear me?
>>Trevor Johns: Yes, we can.
>>Roman Norik: So, the person that asked this
question is actually back on, Achile is here,
Achile do you wanna kind of elaborate on your
question live?
>>Achile: Uh, yeah, I just think that I used
the contextual action bar, top and the bottom,
like on the bottom, but it seems like that
it would get in the way.
I'm writing a notes app, so it's seems like
that would get in the way of the, like, the
actual writing with the palm rest and stuff.
It's gotten in the way when I've used it.
So I just figured if I could put a sideways
action bar it might actually help.
>>Roman Norik: So I think, uh, in some apps,
especially in apps that they require interesting
interactions that aren't just, you know, single
touches or basic gestures, things that sometimes
require the full screen like drawing.
If it's something complex like that then you
shouldn't be limited by our patterns, you
know, if you wanna have actions along the
side, you know, it may make sense.
One of the things to watch out for, though,
is to, is to get a, kind of establish a balance
between what looks like system stuff and what
looks like custom app stuff.
If you make, and this is potentially kind
of unintuitive, but if you make something
that tries to resemble the system graphics
too much, um, it may be, it may feel a little
out of place.
Whereas, if you have something that's kind
of, potentially, styled in your own way and
it's a sideway action bar, it may make more
sense.
So I think that it can work and in a lot of
cases the interaction is correct there, it's
probably better than having things on the
top and bottom but it's definitely something
that requires some special thought just to
figure out, you know, what's the right balance
between, you know, establishing pattern or
established patterns and what's really intuitive
and useful for the user.
>>Achile: Yeah, I'll probably keep it with
the system, normal system UI if I end up doing
it just to avoid, like, confusion with the
user.
>>Roman Norik: Sure and another thing to think
about is, you know, you can always show and
hide things.
So one of the things that happens in video
playback, for example, is that all the controls,
the system bar, the action bar, the status
bar, all that stuff can go away with a single
tap.
And, actually, there was some new APIs in
Jelly Bean which made this very easy and made
it, uh, made the layout very consistent and
stable, actually I think that's the name of
the API, stable across changes to visibility
of things like that.
So you may want to consider doing that as
well.
>>Achile: So lights out mode, like I think
that's what it's called, that's only available
in Jelly Bean?
>>Roman Norik: No, so lights out mode is actually
available with Honeycomb and later, or later.
But Jelly Bean introduced some new things
for devices like the Galaxy Nexus and the
Nexus 7 that have navigation bar, a navigation
bar at the bottom and top.
They introduced the new APIs to make your
layout work even better with that.
So it's also the set system UI visibility
API but there's some new flags in there that
make it even better.
So, I'd look into that.
>> Achile: Okay, thanks.
>>Alex Lucas: One thing I would also note
is like, as Romain mentioned, if you have
a vertical action bar it's gonna be a, adding
this might become an issue because if you're
left handed and it's on the left hand side
of the screen, like, your palm is naturally
gonna fall on it a lot.
So I would say, like, if it's going to, actually
handedness in general becomes an issue with
vertical action bars in touch screen interfaces.
So I'd say at least have the option of moving
it to the other side of the screen.
>>Romain Guy: Or to the top [indistinct]
>>Alex Lucas: Yeah, or stick with the top
cause your hand won't quite, you don't rest
your hand on the top of the screen.
>>Trevor Johns: You also have to keep in mind,
too, you do have the, uh, the system bar at
the bottom which has the home button.
So, if your UI is likely to touch an action
bar at the bottom of the screen, it's just
as likely to touch the system bar as well,
too.
So, and unfortunately you don't really have
the option of moving that.
So, that's something you have to be aware
of as well.
Alright, so, do we have any other live questions
or should we go back to the moderator?
Alright, so back to the moderator it is.
So, the next question comes from mons-, actually
the next question is, my battery's dead.
[Laughs]
>>Alex Lucas: Romain with set it up.
>>Trevor Johns: So, I have the next question.
The next question is they were, the person
was looking at intents service and noticed
that the intents service code was creating
a handler and setting the, uh, the priority
for the thread normal instead of background
priority.
So the question was what's the recommended
approach for background services?
And I think as a side question is, is that
a bug?
So, at least on my end I was taking a look
through the source code earlier and I didn't
actually notice any calls to go and set the
priority within intents service dot Java.
So I'm a little curious where in our code
you saw that behavior.
But as far as with the recommended practices,
Romain do you wanna go and provide some detail
there?
>>Romain Guy: I think the recommend is that
you, by default, is using the default menu
is exactly what you want.
And we give higher priority to, for instance,
if there's a UI in the foreground the user
into interacting with [indistinct] prior to
that.
So you don't necessarily need priority background
to get a lower priority than what's happening
in the foreground.
I don't, I'm not very familiar with intents
services so I'm not sure what the priorities
should be, if it should be background or default
or anything else but I would say that given
that Diane wrote that code, whatever is the
default part is probably what she meant it
to be.
But, of course, we should ask her in case
and see if maybe there is a bug there.
I wouldn't worry about it too much.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, awesome.
Um, so, sadly I can't find a charger anywhere
here so, yeah, let's do this.
I'm gonna read off your laptop.
So, yeah, so, yeah, so the next question is,
"With the voice search app on the Nexus S,
it seems like the UI animation interface can't
keep up with the audio input and response,
so jenk.
So do you have any insight into the most likely
cause or tips on how we can avoid the same
pitfalls?"
And this is from an anonymous user.
>>Romain Guy: Uh, okay, so I will be annoying
with my answer again.
So, once again without knowing more about
exactly what's going on inside the app it's
very hard to, to give tips.
And I don't quite understand when this jenk
is happening but my guess is that it is something
like if you are, do we have real time answers
like, in voice search?
As you speak do we give you real time?
>>Trevor Johns: Yes, on newer versions.
If you're running Android 4., I wanna say
either 4.0 or 4.1, I think it was 4.0, uh,
so that's Ice Cream Sandwich, we added real
time voice transcription.
>>Romain Guy: Well, I mean, there can be several
levels of jenkiness here.
It could be the UI because the missions are
too complicated or it's too much work for
the system or maybe it's just the time it
takes for the audio to be sent to our server,
processed and sent back.
So I'm not quite sure what part of the UI
is in part here.
If the person who has the question can join
the hangout and give us more details about
what's going on and what they're experiencing
then maybe we can try to answer the question.
But, as always, I would say use Trace View.
You can use Trace View on any app and you
can see what's going on and do that in your
applications.
If it is a real problem you should talk to
the people working on the voice search application.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, great.
So I now have questions again on my phone.
My house has been without power for the last
couple days.
I managed to blow a fuse and, yeah, my tablet
has not charged in a couple days.
The fact that it's lasted this long is actually
impressive.
Um, but anyway, moving back to the questions.
Um, so this one comes from Vitali in Albany
New York and the question is, "What's the
benefits of using an intents service over
a thread pull executor for network requests?
Are there any downsides to using thread pull
executor?
We found that the intents service was taking
up about 10 milliseconds to start and handle
an intent, is that correct?"
I'm not hearing anything from Romain so I'm
not sure he has an answer for this one.
>>Romain Guy: Well, I'm trying to remember,
isn't intent service running into a separate
process?
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, so intent service actually
does create a service which may or may not
create a separate process but it does create
a separate task.
So, depending on what the settings for your
app are
>>Romain Guy: Cause if there is truly a 10
millisecond delay it might just be like the
interprocess communication.
But I believe that the whole point of an intent
service is to get the lifecycle management
of system so you don't get [indistinct].
>>Trevor Johns: Right, I mean, even within
the same process activities and services normally
should use inter process communication to
communicate anyways because there's no guarantee
that that service hasn't been configured to
go and start in a different process.
So it's still probably going through field
binder and all of that fun stuff.
>>Romain Guy: I mean the difference here between
using a thread pull and an intent service
is whether or not you want this request to
happen when the app is in the background.
Cause with a service you're app might live
longer in the background and not get killed
so you can still execute things on your intent
service.
Whereas if you're using a thread pull executor
and you're not moving that into your own service
then it's more likely to be killed.
So if you want to wake up your app, you know,
every few minutes or every half an hour to
make a network request, you'd be better off
using the intent service or your own service.
You can write your own service with a thread
pull executor inside.
It's just the intent service is a convenient
way of doing it.
But, thread pull executor is just a loadable
API way to do it.
It's a great way to threading.
There's nothing wrong with it as long as you
know how to use it.
And I know from experience that it's hard.
[Laughter]
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so the next question
is coming from Jason and Jason asks, "Will
anybody update web view to support HTML5 video?"
>>Romain Guy: Yes, we have in Honeycomb.
So as of Honeycomb, if your application is
hardware accelerated, you get full HTML5 video
support.
So make sure your app is either using the
target SDK14 or you're using the user hardware
accelerated equals true attribute in your
manifest and then you will get HTML video
support.
>>Trevor Johns: Excellent.
Now, see, I thought it actually hadn't been
implemented yet so that's great news.
>>Alex Lucas: Our hardware team is so fast
they'll take a future request, go back in
time and implement it.
>>Trevor Johns: That's true.
Maybe you could fix the Tardis.
Yeah, it's right there behind me for those
of you who can't see.
Our Tardis is broken so normally questions
like this we actually can't answer because
we can't talk about the roadmap for Android,
right?
Until things get released, at least.
But when things are already implemented that's
awesome.
So, I'm glad we could help you with that.
So let's move on to the next question here.
>>Male #1: Hey Trevor, I actually got a question
from the hangout.
>>Trevor Johns: Ah, excellent.
More hangout questions go ahead.
>>Male #1: So the question is actually regarding
Hebrew.
It's supposed to have been fixed as of the
current version of Android but it's gonna
be awhile before OAMs actually start introducing
the latest version.
So it could take up to, quote unquote, two
years before it's out there in the wild.
Are there any fixes for this issue that we,
that developers can implement right now?
>>Romain Guy: Not easily.
You would have to, it would be difficult,
you would have to take your library like half
[indistinct] like what we use to save complex
scripts and then you would have to do your
own text frame to be able to position the
glyphs properly.
So, Skia on the canvas API we have method
called draw [inaudible] text that helps a
little bit but it's a been broken for languages
like Hebrew.
So it would be, actually, pretty difficult
to do on your own.
And I would not recommend doing it yourself
because it's a lot of work and it's easy to
get it wrong.
So I wish, you know, I had a better answer
for you and I wish I could tell you that it's
been supported since 1O but unfortunately
our in server, it's gonna be in a future version
of Android.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, great.
So, next question is coming from Simon M.
in, no Simon M. Nancy in France.
Either that or the city of Nancy, France,
I'm pretty sure it's Simon M. Nancy.
>>Romain Guy: There is a Nancy, France.
>>Trevor Johns: There is a Nancy, France?
Okay, so I guess Nancy is a strange last name.
Alright, so, Simon, he asks, "Is there a way
to attach a kind of selector like a stateless
drawable to a text view in order to update
the text shadow attributes with touches, clicks,
photos, etcetera?"
>>Romain Guy: No, you cannot.
You can only change the text color and drawables
is in the text view drawables should have
drawables but you cannot change the shadow.
So what you can, though, is you can overwrite
text view and then there's a method, I believe,
called drawable state changed, it's a protective
method you can override that will be invoked
every time the state of the view changes and
that state needs to be propagated to the drawables
so, for instance, if the view goes from [indistinct]
things like that and from there you can go
change yourself to a set of attributes.
I have to admit that this is not something
that we thought would be useful and I'll think
about it and see if we should add that to
the framework but, you know, it seems to be,
it will probably be low on our list of priorities
if we do write it.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, great.
So, um, next question here.
This is from Harish from Berk, wherever that
is, and he asks, "When I run my app in Jelly
Bean using the eclipse simulator I get a warning
saying choreographer skipped 2001 frames,
the application may be doing too much work
on its main thread.
How can I overcome this?
How does it.